quando ferdinando mi ha contattato per
questo evento mi ha detto sai ho in
mente di organizzare una conferenza sul
tema del potere dell'amore io ho pensato
poverini gli speaker fai poi mi ha detto
avevo pensato a te come lo degli
italiani da invitare e quindi questa è
una sfida che io accetto molto
volentieri perché io nella vita come
diceva appunto federando mi occupo di
tre cose di sostenibilità di innovazione
e di leadership e ispirato dal titolo di
questa conferenza mi sono interrogato su
cosa queste tre cose avessero a che fare
con il potere dell'amore
e in effetti ho realizzato che queste
tre cose hanno molto a che fare con il
potere dell'amore e quello che vorrei
fare con voi nei prossimi minuti è
invitarvi in un piccolo viaggio in cui
vi chiederei la cortesia anche l'onore
di sospendere se possibile il vostro
giudizio e assecondare questa mia questo
mio invito di seguirmi in alcune
suggestioni che non hanno la pretesa di
avere valore scientifico ma solamente
quello di ispirare attraverso meemi e
attraverso un percorso logico una
riflessione su queste tre cose e su cosa
queste tre cose hanno a che fare col
potere dell'amore e quindi cominciamo il
nostro viaggio attraversando questo
simbolico magico specchio di parnassus è
la prima cosa che troviamo al di là di
questo specchio di parnassus nel nostro
viaggio è l'immagine di una galassia di
una galassia tra le miliardi
nell'universo tra le miliardi di
galassie che con miliardi di soli che
scadono miliardi di pianeti che esistono
da miliardi di anni
io devo dire la verità non sono
particolarmente ferrato in maniera in
materia di astronomia astrofisica però
non vi nascondo che quando guardo il
cielo stellato di sera immagino che
magari alcuni di voi anche succederà la
prima reazione che ho non è quella di
cercare di capire tutto questo che cos'è
come funziona da dove è venuto e dove
sta andando
ma semplicemente di rimanere in qualche
modo a bocca aperta è stupito e
meravigliato di quello che questo
spettacolo
finito ad offrire nostri occhi perché
come diceva shakespeare nell'amleto ci
sono più cose in cielo in terra che
nella tua filosofia orazio e questo
credo che sia una delle cose che
risuonano dentro di me in maniera più
profonda non soltanto quando guardo al
cielo stellato ma quando pensi in
generale al mistero della vita e della
natura e cioè il fatto che c'è una
generale tendenza di difficoltà a
concepire in maniera tutto sommato
confortevole il mistero o il non sapere
e ci rende in qualche modo vulnerabili
ci venne in qualche modo sensibili e
questo è da una parte qualcosa che
attrae e affascina ma dall'altra
qualcosa che spinge sempre a cercare
delle risposte a cercare dei modelli a
cercare delle teorie a cercare di capire
di comprendere come funziona il
meccanismo di macchine o organismi molto
complessi come l'universo i pianeti o
anche cose molto più a portata di mano
nella vita quotidiana
ecco questa incapacità secondo me di
vivere col mistero e non sapere è una
capacità che però in qualche modo a che
fare con questo che in mezzo a questi
miliardi di pianeti è il nostro e per
uno scherzo del destino un miracolo o un
caso cosmico è pieno di vita e questa
immagine anche se non è quello originale
e molto simile all'immagine che
l'equipaggio dell'apollo 8 nel 68 vite
per primo che proiettò per primo di
riflesso verso di noi sulla terra nella
sua missione verso la luna e
quell'equipaggio della pole 8 era stato
mandato in missione dall'onu per conto
dell'umanità per esplorare lo spazio
cosmico e per riportarci dallo spazio
cosmico uno sguardo sul nostro pianeta
beh ci sono racconti testimonianze delle
persone che hanno fatto parte di quella
equipaggio che dicono che per loro
l'immagine del nostro pianeta vista
dallo spazio nella sua unità nella sua
interezza
ha rappresentato l'opportunità di
un'esperienza spirituale trasformativa
la prima volta che il genere umano
vedeva per intero questa astronave
chiamata terra che galleggiava al centro
della via lattea è un pianeta il nostro
pieno di vita
piero di forme di vita che con
l'eccezione della nostra specie vivono
in armonia con l'ambiente che le
circonda vivono connesse con l'ambiente
che le circonda vivono connesse tra di
loro e sono tutte in qualche modo forma
riflesso e rappresentazione di questa
sostanziale unità della vita e queste
connessioni questa rete della vita sono
tema ricorrente nell'universo del nostro
pianeta perché in qualche modo se
guardiamo a questa immagine che è una
rappresentazione delle connessioni delle
linee di comunicazione attive sono
stabilite ci rendiamo conto che la
spinta naturale a connetterci ad altro a
connetterci ad altri è una spinta che a
qualsiasi livello che sia un livello
organico scientifico tecnologico
semplicemente di comunicazione è una
spinta innata è una spinta naturale è
qualcosa che ci fa attendere in qualche
modo la ricerca dell'altro del diverso e
dell'unità poi ovviamente si può
obiettare sul fatto che tutte queste
linee di comunicazione aperta servano
obiettivamente poi a trasferire del
significato o del senso o della visione
piuttosto che magari semplicemente
permetterci di scambiare transazioni
finanziarie in maniera più veloce in
quantità più elevata o in qualche modo
riempire i nostri delle scienze dei
nostri adolescenti di una sovrabbondanza
di informazioni ma tant'è che il tema
della connessione e dell'unità è un tema
che ritorna e ritorna in natura e
ritorna anche quando guardiamo per
esempio alle connessioni sinaptiche
all'interno del nostro cervello queste
connessioni sinaptiche che rappresentano
una rete di stimoli elettrici che genera
pensieri idee genera possibili nuovi
mondi genera sogni genera ciò che siamo
e ciò che racconta ma gli altri e questa
idea ancora una volta di essere in
qualche modo difficilmente capaci di
resi
per la tentazione di mappare il cervello
come abbiamo già mappato il genoma umano
senza peraltro capire che cosa volesse
dire una mappatura che ne abbiamo fatto
per lo meno non ancora però l'abbiamo
mappato e stiamo cominciando a creare
delle mappe più dettagliate più precisa
del nostro cervello cercando ancora una
volta di capirne il funzionamento di
capirne in qualche modo il senso
piuttosto che semplicemente ammirare il
fatto che sia uno dei miracoli della
natura un mondo connesso e unito ma una
specie la nostra che devo dire non ha
fatto un gran lavoro nell'onorare questa
sostanziale unità non ha fatto un gran
lavoro perché nel corso della storia
sono tanti i muri che noi abbiamo
innalzato tra di noi che abbiamo
innalzato tra religioni tra filosofie
tra itri e abbiamo innalzato muri alti
fisici dove innalzato frontiere e
minacciato muri di incomunicabilità
nelle nostre coppie abbiamo innalzato
delle divisioni dei muri che in qualche
modo sono un tradimento è un affronto a
questo a questa idea di fondo di questa
sostanziale unità del nostro pianeta e
del nostro ruolo in questo tenete e
queste divisioni a questi muri in
qualche modo vengono da un certo modo di
pensare un certo modo di concepire il
nostro vivere insieme un certo modo di
concepire il modello di funzionamento
delle nostre organizzazioni o delle
nostre società o delle nostre comunità
che ha alle spalle un pensiero
positivista illuminista che ha diciamo
in qualche modo la credenza di poter
comprendere tutto sacrificando ciò che
forse più importante e cioè il senso
dell'essere insieme il senso del
condividere un destino comune
il senso dell'avere una interdipendenza
che non è semplicemente qualcosa che
abbiamo scoperto ma che è sempre stata
la e sempre ci sarà e quindi la domanda
che mi sono fatto in entrata questa
conferenza
come possiamo conciliare progresso e
sostenibilità come possiamo conciliare
tutte queste divisioni e questi muri che
abbiamo innalzato con questa idea di
fondo di queste connessioni e di questo
senso di essere una cosa sola di essere
in qualche modo legati in questa
sostanza era unita come consiglierei
valori approfitto come conciliare cose
che sembrano così distanti fra di loro e
così dicotomiche da essere in qualche
modo difficilmente riconciliabili ma io
credo che la risposta sia nella parola
innovazione e cioè nella capacità di
portare qualcosa di nuovo nel mondo e
questo qualcosa di nuovo nel mondo a che
fare con la possibilità di riuscire a
trovare delle vie per conciliare queste
opposti per conciliare queste dicotomie
per trascenderle includere per andare
oltre per cercare di rimodellare il
nostro modo di pensare e così facendo
rifondare le nostre organizzazioni e le
nostre istituzioni più sempre sentirsi
che sa fare mi direte voi ma io vorrei
offrirvi molto modestamente due
esperienze tra le altre che in qualche
modo mi hanno visto coinvolto nel corso
della mia vita e che sono secondo me un
esempio di ciò che vorrei cercare di
comunicare e queste due esperienze che
non sono due tsunami o due terremoti ma
in qualche modo se vogliamo usare la
metafora avrebbero o hanno potuto
generare delle onde di cambiamento sono
due esperienze molto differenti tra loro
ma che hanno dei punti in comune che mi
piacerebbe sottolineare la prima
esperienza a che fare con una grande
multinazionale di cui all'epoca avevo
solamente 26 anni era un giovane
idealista che voleva cambiare il mondo
però aveva anche la fortuna di
lavorare nell'ufficio del chairman e
quindi di una delle persone più
importanti di questa azienda da 150 mila
persone in 140 paesi e insieme ad altri
giovani idealisti come me tutti i
colleghi e amici abbiamo pensato che
sarebbe stata un'ottima idea convincere
questa gigante questa azienda
multinazionale a cambiare completamente
rotta ea trasformarsi in un azienda che
potesse essere un esempio di
sostenibilità e di attenzione
all'ambiente e al sociale
e così facendo trasformare l'industria
di cui questa azienda faceva parte e
così facendo cambiare il mondo e quindi
ci mettiamo al lavoro in maniera stealth
in materia invisibile e ci facevo
finanziare queste attività interne
l'azienda da un gruppo di top manager
che erano oramai vicino al pensionamento
interessante questa connessione fra
questi giovani idealisti e questi top
manager che in qualche modo aveva nel
desiderio di lasciare al mondo e
all'azienda un'eredità che non fosse
solamente quella di aver aperto nuove
sedi aver conquistato nuovi mercati o
colonizzato nuove società e questo
progetto che ha avuto la durata di
qualche anno ha prodotto risultati molto
interessanti
l'azienda veramente cominciato a
riflettere su se stessa sul proprio
ruolo nel mondo ha cominciato ad
attivare iniziative diciamo abbastanza
alla periferia non al centro non
all'interno del quartier generale perché
questa era un progetto che non volevano
prendere troppa l'attenzione perché l'ha
giudicato in qualche modo un po
controverso era un progetto che aveva un
qualcosa di sovversivo anche se nel
senso buono del termine
beh per fare la storia abbastanza breve
dopo una serie di risultati molto
interessanti
questo progetto finalmente ottenne il
riconoscimento ufficiale formale da
parte dell'organizzazione era per noi il
culmine di un lavoro durato quattro anni
in cui abbiamo sicuramente provato
diverse vie diverse cose diverse
soluzioni e quello che ci siamo trovati
di fronte era un riconoscimento che si è
trasformato nella fine
dell'anima di questo progetto stesso e
cioè il fatto che l'azienda
riconoscendolo come un progetto
ufficiale in qualche modo ne ucciso il
moto di innovazione il moto di valori
che c'erano e c'erano le basi l'altro
esempio è quello di un villaggio
africano che ho avuto la fortuna in
qualche modo di entrare in contatto già
all'epoca della sua fondazione è uno
degli altri speaker che verrà tra poco è
un'altra persona che è in contatto con
questo villaggio appena fuori harari
qualche chilometro fuori harare questo
villaggio è molto interessante perché è
un villaggio che in qualche modo la
pretesa di diventare un modello di
sostenibilità indipendente nei confronti
del apparato statale dal punto di vista
della moneta dal punto di vista
dell'energia dal punto di vista
dell'alimentazione di diventare un
centro indipendente proprio perché
sappiamo tutti che lo zimbello in
qualche modo è sottomesso a una
dittatura che in qualche modo tiene in
maniera anche violenta sotto gli
abitanti dello zimbabwe lo zimbabwe cosa
di bello questo villaggio che non
soltanto vuoi diventare un esempio per
gli altri ma vuole insegnare a tutti gli
altri villaggi e farle così facendo
alimentando un circolo virtuoso in cui
dal basso si genera anche una volta una
piccola rivoluzione una piccola
innovazione che toglie potere alla
struttura centrale dello stato e così
facendo mira a cambiare il modo in cui i
cittadini vivono quel paese quella
nazione cosa hanno in comune queste due
esperienze hanno in comune una tre cose
molto importanti la prima è che
l'innovazione sociale
dalla mia esperienza può avvenire e può
avere successo e può attecchire
solamente alla periferia del sistema non
al centro del sistema la seconda cosa
che ho imparato è che ha bisogno di
essere alimentata da persone che credono
che questo possa realmente rappresentare
qualcosa di nuovo e questa a che fare
con la leadership ci tornerò fra un
minuto e la terza è che oggi nel book
awards ho imparato la parola grazie a
kevin roberts in un mondo in cui c'è
disordine c'è confusione non è mai stato
così semplice poter avviare
questo tipo di iniziativa abbiamo
soltanto bisogno di più massa critica e
ne esistono già migliaia di esempi in
tutto il mondo
abbiamo bisogno di un certo tipo di
leader e qui viene in qualche modo la
mia ultima il mio ultimo passaggio che
questo ideale viaggio di quale
leadership abbiamo bisogno oggi john
keats poeta coniato l'espressione
veramente molto interessante che ha a
che fare con questo il concetto di
negativ capabilities di capacità
negativa e cioè la capacità di rimanere
nel mistero e nel non sapere come si
andrà a finire
e nonostante questo riuscire a
conciliare degli apparenti opposti delle
apparenti dicotomie e ascoltando al
centro del caos e del disordine ciò che
apparentemente caos disordine ma magari
sono segnali di un uovo che vuole
emergere aiutare questo nuovo ad
emergere ea venire al mondo e questa
qualità della leadership
questo modo di intendere il ruolo di
aiutare in qualche modo le cose che
vogliono già essere portata alla luce ad
essere portate alla luce questo lavorio
della leadership di riuscire a portare
nel mondo qualcosa di nuovo a che fare
con questa immagine di un film famoso in
cui messaggio è che non è il cucchiaio
che si piega siamo semmai noi che ci
pieghiamo perché cucchiaio semplicemente
non esiste come non esistono i muri come
non esistono le divisioni come non
esiste tutto ciò che abbiamo messo tra
di noi proprio perché sono idee e di
persone e come tali possono essere
soppiantate da nuove idee di nuove
persone e queste nuove idee di queste
nuove persone possono attecchire da ogni
dove possono nascere da ogni dove
ma soprattutto dalla nostra mente dalle
nostre idee perché noi siamo fatti della
stessa sostanza dei sogni
come diceva nuovamente shakespeare nella
sua tempesta
e cioè se possiamo immaginarlo possiamo
realizzarlo
e se possiamo realizzarlo possiamo
raccontarlo e se possiamo raccontarlo
possiamo ispirare altri a fare
altrettanto
e così facendo in qualche modo
reincantare il mondo e cercare insieme
magari già in questa sala
dalla fine di questa conferenza a
comprendere che tutto ciò che accade
tu lo scrivi disse la di sera infante
imperatrice no tutto ciò che io scrivo
accadde fu la risposta
e quindi il mio invito in questa sede è
quello di cercare di chiudere questo
breve viaggio che abbiamo fatto insieme
e se avremo capito che ciò che di fondo
c'è è un'unità che le divisioni e i muri
sono soltanto un'illusione ottica e che
possiamo portare un cambiamento anche a
partire dal caos e che possiamo farlo
insieme scrivendo una storia diversa
ognuno nel suo ognuno nel proprio allora
forse avremmo cominciato a capire il
potere dell'amore grazie